the event was hosted by Borders
bookstore in Washington DC
hey I'd say you'd be how are you hi
everyone thanks for coming out this is
our third book signing this week one in
New Jersey one last night in the clay
abyss effects an important one today in
Orlando now this first okay okay hey no
legs you're told
thanks for coming appreciate it sending
those to Texas its East like middle
school I believe it's on the east side
of El Paso oh great that's right my
grandmother survived a minute my mother
the old school was sinking in the ground
so they built a new a new 34 million
dollar 100
yeah the library
can you show us the book there how long
did you have to wait to get your book
signed oh yeah it was a very long time
yeah why would you wait so long to get
your book signed we wanted to see
describe experience was really exciting
how long were you there
I talk to a lot of
what kind of books do are your favorite
stories about animals and
I like stories about the lazy people
I don't like the same things that I
but I don't like it when like they're
all smoothies everyone
basically me too I like that but some
friction marks and like
looks about they really have two new
people that are funny things like that
before I let you go could you please
show me the signature inside you go
[Laughter]
there you go you memorize the book
there's a problem Thank you very
my name is Paul Giovanni from Hillsdale
New Jersey
and what are you doing here what did you
try making new dresses yeah we're
vacationing in Washington DC this is
sort of like by chance we came to this
book signing and why did you wait in
this long line I think my wife could
answer this question it's better because
her idea I'm a speech teacher in
elementary school and this is going in
the library of our school it's just
awesome
it's just we were so excited today to be
your children's names could you show us
the signature
how long did you have to wait we're not
here at five o'clock it's now 7:15 so
two hours but those wonderful people in
line and it was a very interesting
experience it really was a wonderful
part of our Washington my name is Becky
campaigner and I'm from Massachusetts
just never it's kind of like a dream
like you never think you're ever gonna
meet the president's wife or heard their
children so they're just really exciting
and they ask questions and we're very
interested in in our lives in what we do
so it was really excited and rest masses
where we from and I actually said that
we were and educated we were teaching
Posse and she's oh that's really nice
and you know kind of think about things
after you say they're not coops I just
said that but that's okay and they say
well that he asked us if we want I
spring break which we are and then
they've talked a little bit about you
know they're teaching and whatnot so
it's really it was really fun
[Music]
that's President George HW Bush prettier
than that Rascal Flatts and my name is
Lynette fuller I'm from Alexandria
Virginia
I wanted to book and I wanted a sign I
have a stack of books that I use in my
library
autograph articles authors yes
so you collect I collect yeah
Bill Clinton giving I have jimick
wattersmith
latest book and I have
oh I'm John Lewis this book Dorothy
Height yeah I have a good collection now
describe your experience here in your
your short time there with
all fabulous I had gone to book signing
before and I got on a story so I had I
told Jenna I had seen her around
Christmastime I got the book signed by
her now seeing her again this time with
her mother so I got double my words here
tonight we like having all the little
babies that's our favorite part thank
you very much cousin please hang in
through there you're a crying baby in
what break Virginia
and you're me I'm Karen and with Richard
Sherman I live in Woodbridge Virginia
what'd you think of hitting the first
lady and gent exciting
have you ever done
to go
impress me Carter
and yes there's a time
many other people
and what was it like did you talk
I talked about
second grade I'm in Ashland Elementary
I
time
don't worry
what's your favorite kind of story would
you
[Music]
today
thank you great story my grandmother oh
great well thank you so much hi how are
you thank you very much thank you
appreciate it
thanks so much for coming they wanted to
instructions are so cute we loved our
illustrate adults with it my name is
Sadie Williams and I'm from
Alabama and what brings you to
Washington
we came to spend a weekend I came with
some other friends and we just came to
spend a weekend and tour the city go to
the White House and
we found out about the book signings
that we were excited about that want to
come again
the book can have the good sense how
long did you wait
see don't worry within the hour and an
hour and a half
oh it was neat we were tired and we you
know were waiting but when we got up
there was exciting it was very neat to
get to she's a better thing liver is
very very nice and gracious
well I think she's just a beautiful
gracious first way and I think Jenna's a
very
things to take after another finally
what are you gonna do if your bookie
so much hey what's your name what's your
name Ashley do you like Ashley we hope
you like this book what do you think so
far
do you think it's funny if you like the
P who is your favorite character
thank you all for coming we're glad you
like the book my name's Adam Street I'm
from Cecil County Maryland and what why
did you wait for two hours to get a book
sign President Bush has been a big
supporter police officer and police
officer and we came out here to support
him and his family very big
republicanism and what was your
experience like have you met the first
lady before it was very nice her and
Jenna we gave them each a Sheriff's
Office patch and they seemed to really
appreciate it's on the books for us and
it was really neat yeah very nice time
you have some pictures you took there I
do this is a picture of me with the
first lady and again here and I have
here Jenna and mrs. Bush signing the
books I think I'm right here you're the
honorary chair of my school board the
lab school of Washington Walker last
year was a really terrific interim years
yeah I'm hoping to try to help some of
my students from Elsa little Stoke
supply it's a less good very important
school in whoever that's great
you've been watching a book signing of
first lady Laura Bush and her daughter
Jenna of their co-authored children's
book read all about it